et là on est en direct du studio 2
jérôme salut jérôme si tu nous vois on
est en train de tout squatté moi je
touche a déjà fait renier si c'était et
si c'était si c'était que toucher dans
quoi on embarque tu as tout a les cartes
en dehors et oasis seconde tatum
voilà je prends quelques beaux mecs me
fatiguer je ne sais pas comment y est je
sais pas quoi il tourne je l'avais butin
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mme
encore aujourd'hui je ne suis pas chez
moi
pour une raison simple mais blizzard
puisqu'il juillet pourquoi puisqu'on a
avec nous aujourd'hui pour nous parler
et je suis albert ii se signer là bas je
vais devoir tout recommencer à zéro et
bien albert ii est sous estimé et je
vous en parle beaucoup d'albert sur la
chaîne ne mène pas mal donc
merci albert et puis allez faire un tour
sur sos signer avant tout voilà c'est
cool il ya plein de matos et le mec sait
de quoi il parle
donc aujourd'hui albert on parle
d'objectif l'objectif ce qu'on met
devant le capteur c'est ça tout le monde
parle de boîtiers maintenant parce
qu'israël facettes est roi parce que le
gh1 que c'est mieux que le h4 est ce que
je peux faire avec quatre cas avec mon
téléphone
mais on parle pas suffisamment de ce
qu'on est devant et ce qui compte
énormément c'est le caillou c'est
l'optique faut savoir que pour un un
boîtier acheter généralement on va
acheter deux trois objectifs objectif
j'en ai 1 2 3 4 5 et 5 5 mais je tu vois
je les utilise pas tous et des fois je
me dis que j'en entre où tu vois des
trucs et puis quand je les revends mais
depuis que j'ai plus celui que j'ai
revendu je dis merde français
il manque la cour le coach va donc c'est
pour ça tu vas peut-être pouvoir nous
éclairer parce que il ya tellement de
sortes d'objectifs que c'est un des fois
un peu compliqué de savoir par quoi
commencer ce qu'il faut acheter et à
quoi ça va servir et pour qui c'est on
va pas je peux vous dire qu'elle est
meilleure objectivité ce qu'il faut pour
commencer je vais vous donner les
notions les théories et puis ensuite ce
sera à vous en fonction de ce que vous
voulez de faire vos choix alors il ya
les deux grandes familles d'objectif on
pense au zoom ap aux focales fixes la
différence entre le zoom et le fixe
c'est que un fixe c'est un fixe s'est il
a une seule valeur focale smcc un zoom
c'est quelque chose c'est un objectif
qui va se balader dans les valeurs
locales j'adore fait donc sa fixette a
fixé un zoom c'est un zoom dézoom c'est
ce ballet l'année la meilleure
explication la meilleure explication
optique du monde merci d'avoir regarder
ça avec nous on à bercy ses sous pour
nous à la gêne allez salut
plus sérieusement il ya beaucoup de
choses à savoir dans l'optique en fait
il ya la qualité optique
en fait le vert ce qui se passe avec le
vert c'est que ça filtre les rayons
lumineux et en fonction de cette qualité
ça va prendre plus ou moins de longueur
d'onde
donc tu vas avoir des verts qui ont des
dominantes bleues des dominantes rouge
ça va te permettre de tracts et de
traiter en post-production ton image
différemment en fonction des optiques
que tu utilises alors je pars vous
expliquer toutes les mains toutes les
optiques comment les verts sont
fabriqués il ya aussi l'intérieur de
l'optique comment elle est fabriquée au
niveau du focus pulling delà de la bague
de focus et on parlera tout ça et vous
pourrez juger de de ce que vous voulez
pour vous est ce qu'il veut vous faire
du bien
du coup on commence par quoi alors et
bah si on regarde et tout ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
regardons tout ce qu'on apprend variable
soit il ya juste deux trois objets en
sais rien pas tous là n'est pas tout la
fin des parties où c'est parti donc tu
nous as mis quand même là sur la table
pas mal de petites faims mal d'optique
shemie vraiment des optiques haut de
gamme et moderne parce que on peut aussi
adapter des vieilles optique sur nos
boîtiers à l'aide de bague
il ya les montures il ya tout ça qui
existe enfin les optiques là aujourd'hui
on va décrocher le sujet dessus il ya
beaucoup de notions à connaître la faute
enfin ce que c'est qu'une ouverture faut
comprendre aussi que chaque fabricant a
sa propre bague donc son système de
clips ce de l'optique et qu'en fonction
des optiques qu'on achète faut parfois
acheter des adaptateurs
l'idée c'est plus de dire à qui ça se
destine et les avantages et les
inconvénients
deux de ces objectifs parce qu'ils sont
tous différents ils ont touche
complètement différent c'est vraiment
des objectifs encore une fois dans le
haut du panier
là on a le 50 mm 5
sigma à 1.4 qui est connu comme étant
l'un des meilleurs 50 photos du marché
il ya son équivalent en cinéma qu'on n'a
pas là là on à 1,50 samyang qui est fou
le manuel
ici on a deux zooms alors pourquoi j'en
ai sorti deux parce qu'on a le 24 70 us
m2 cannon au serial qu'on leur connaît
grâce à la petite voiture rouge
classique et là on a le le 18 35 sigma
1.8 et il ya une énorme différence
alors entre les deux c'est que celui-là
et pour le full frame les suis là pour
la ps et ilyas à savoir aussi quand tu
achètes pour d'optique si il va aller
sur ton sur ta taille de capteur quand
tu achètes des objectifs qui soient
micro 4/3 ou format aps c donc super 35
généralement c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle hubert la psc ça ne va pas aller
sur les foules fremm pour les montures
plus frais que vous achetez des
objectifs ff alors que l'inversé
possible alors que la mère c'est tout à
fait impossible déjà en choisissent
quand on choisit un objectif qu'on ne me
connaît pas forcément grand chose il
faut regarder voilà le format la monture
est donc si ces deux-là pc-6 et du micro
4/3 si c'est du coup le frame parce que
sinon on va se retrouver avec du crop
par exemple la tp et moi une question
que je me pose alors je fais semblant me
pose est pourquoi j'irai prendre
un 50 mm ici je fais que du 50 mm quand
je peux avoir ici un 24 105 et je peux
avoir du 50 mm du 24 du sang cinq
voiliers l'ouverture déjà sur sur des
sur des optiques un fixe sur des prime
c'est comme ça qu'on dit on dit des
prime time et ouverture qui sont plus
rapides qui ouvre plus qu'il a ce pas
chez qui laisse passer plus de lumière
qui sont plus lumineuses et qui permet
d'avoir aussi un truc de coke et qu'on
cherche ou d'arrière-plan et d'avant de
l'homme voilà et d'avant-plan les dames
van wyk et d'inventer g20 c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai et il serait que
tu là dessus on peut aller sur des sur
des prime on peut aller jusqu'à 4 5 1
0,95 là on est sur lui un 4 1 4 c'est
déjà énorme
la bête est lourde alors que sur des
zooms on entendra m'avait jamais vu des
zooms en dessous de 8 20 8 mai sur la ps
cela ps est d'abord parce que ça permet
de la paix à ces permet de faire des
optiques qui sont justement plus compact
alors beaucoup qu'est ce qui se passe
dans un zoom tu vois quand je tourne la
bague way pour pour changer de focale
qu'est ce qui se passe dedans en fait là
tu as deux groupes optiques qui sont dès
qu'ils sont mis sur des sur des pivots
carré d'ailleurs avec des optiques
rondes et quand tu bouges des groupes
optiques qui bouge là c'était loupe qui
bouge et latin une autre d'un aspect
amical qui est là et qui va des
focaliser se refocaliser affaire afin de
faire la mise au point mais sur des
optiques photo en fait ici c'est comme
si tu avais un mini soum qui travaillait
et qui va aller rechercher la mise au
point en reculant et en avançant c'est
exactement le même système sur les sur
les cinémas mais comme généralement tu
as des états des lentilles qui sont
beaucoup plus grosse et des systèmes qui
sont beaucoup plus aboutie tapas cet été
30 pages ça mais tu l'as partout hein
tu les fais de pompage tu vas l'avoir
sur un zoom mais tu vois aussi la voir
sur ton prime et c'est l'autre problème
des zooms photo c'est quand tu changes
ta mise au point et ben tu perds ton
point ça c'est un autre souci d une
photo sur des zooms sur des zooms à
caractère cinématographique
t'auras pas ça passe comme ça ta pâte
honda pâton tonga qui est constamment en
train de rattraper la mise au point
pendant que il est en train de changer
de changer ça ouais et alors question
est-ce que sur
sur une focale fixe j'ai une meilleure
image que sur un zoom ça dépend du zoom
ça dépend des focales fixes mais c'est
plus simple à construire en fait à moins
d'éléments optique - tas d'éléments
optique dans l'optique où l'image est
nette
sahorre qu'à chaque fois que tu veux la
lumière traverse une optique elle est
déformé tu vois et ensuite tu as des
optiques concave des choses comme ça
pour essayer de rétablir en fait le
faisceau lumineux et et avoir une image
la moins déformée possible et avec lui
la meilleure colorimétrie possible mais
plus tu as de groupe d'éléments optique
dedans plus les rayons lumière sont
absorbés ça va ça va retenir certaines
longueurs d'onde donc dans un zoom comme
il ya plus d'élément optique une image à
une moins bonne qualité que dans un prêt
ça on en a déjà parlé sur la chaîne on
allait parler justement de des optiques
dean nationale de la p'tite signer ouais
maillot jaune assorti de différents
turrel font pas même bois que ça que
c'est si elle est lourde à celle ci
c'est la toxine allemagne c'est la
toxine naturelles sont pas du tout
construite pareil tu attends peut les
ouvrir
c'est pas pareil cas c'est quoi la
différence là du coup tu as ici quelque
chose de crevin déjà il ya 3000 euros de
différence entre le nerf déjà récompense
on est sur quoi je crois que je suis en
bas il ya plusieurs différences
notamment au niveau des ja de ta mise au
point tu vois là j'ai une bague graduée
ouais sur celle là qui qui fait 300
degrés d'accord tu vois j'ai 300 degrés
de pivot sûr
mon focus pulling d'accord alors que là
c'est beaucoup plus court comme mars
voilà j'ai l'âge et 180 donc la viande
tu as encore plus précis en fait sur
sable a raconté que je suis extrêmement
plus précis là-dessus
d'accord je peux aller beaucoup plus
près beaucoup plus loin et surtout quand
mon sujet bouge
g j'ai beaucoup plus de latitude pour
qu'ils sortent de mon point que sur
cette optique là est encore beaucoup
plus que là dessus puisque la gg à peine
45 degrés la construction optique
absolument pas pareil ouais tu vois là
on va avoir un énorme énorme frontale
ouais et on va avoir moins de groupe
d'éléments qui sont beaucoup plus c'est
pareil dans l'optique alors que là on a
une à une et une frontale qui est
beaucoup plus petit
ouais tu vois faire attendre alors que
là on est athée 1.5 et là aussi un ouais
on est sur une même transmission c'est
quand même assez ou celia à la qualité
finale on n'a pas du tout la même
qualité finale on n'a pas le même prix
mais on n'a pas du tout la même qui a
été filmé par un procédé optique
parce que là tu voudrais quand même
sorti de dix mille balles de wella sur
la table ça va venir
bon bah écoute albert merci pour nous
avoir montré tous ces trucs et tous et
tout ce matos qui est juste juste kouf
avant de remettre ton masque il ya un
truc à faire parce que les abonnés ils
le savent aussi si la vidéo lors leur a
plu lorenza plus il a un fils est aussi
taza plus long senio et est ce que parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas avait bases simples
plus bleu l'a aimé la bonne voie là mais
dans l es tu tire un coup de la star y
est par là le pouce bleu tu vois voilà
hathaway
vas-y groupe leurs symptômes
voila voila je regarde cette vidéo table
htc à la fin tu restes pascal atteint
3,1 et puis voici ça si ça vous a plus
en plus du coût de blatter pouvez vous
abonner
si c'est pas déjà fait glisser vos
commentaires l'instinct g aussi dans la
boîte
exactement on n'a pas su fédérer avec la
td story avec toi dedans
on commence à faire des soirées marrante
et moi je vous dis bien rester curieux
et à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo eux tombent au sol alors oui le
titre il est un petit peu racoleur on
est d'accord mais le contenu cette vidéo
il était tellement intéressant je
voulais vraiment que vous alliez voir et
écouter ce que ce que ce qu'on s'est dit
avec albert et puis si j'avais mis ce
titre là je me suis dit que vous aviez
peut-être passé à côté de quelque chose
donc voilà pour le titre et puis coeur
sur vous je vous fais des bisous à très
bientôt